[Music]
2008 of the Republican big Republican
presidential candidates they were asked
how many of you believe in in Darwinian
biological evolution two-thirds or
three-quarters said I do 2012 same
question asked same group of people
Republican presidential candidates it
was already down to a third 2016 the 17
people main candidates for the
Republican nomination asked do you
believe in evolution one Jeb Bush brave
Jeb Bush said he did but he said walking
it back even as he said it I'm not sure
should be taught in our public schools
and if it is it should be taught along
with creationism so from 2008 to 2016
that was the change and that changes I
don't believe all those people believed
what they said I don't think all of them
just believe in evolution some of them
but they were all obliged to to say yes
to to falsehood and magical thinking of
this religious kind and and that's where
it becomes problematic America has
always been a Christian nation that
meant a very different thing 100 years
ago or even 50 years ago then it means
today I grew up not going to church very
often at all and not with much religious
education but all of my friends were
weekly regular churchgoers of various
kinds Christian Protestant religion
became extreme became more magical and
supernatural in its beliefs and
practices in America then then it had
been in hundreds of years and and and
more so than it is anywhere else in the
developed world so you have that
happening at the same time not
coincidentally you have the Republican
Party beginning certainly by 30 years
ago becoming more and more a party of
those religiously extreme Protestants
so it one thing that has happened and
one thing that has led I think the
Republican Party to accept fantasy and
and and and wishful untruth more and
more into its approach to policy whether
its climate change or or or the idea
that secret Muslim conspiracy is about
to replace our constitutional judiciary
system with Sharia law or or any number
of other simply untrue tenets of
republicanism all these things which
were nutty fringe ideas as recently as
30 years ago are now in the Republican
mainstream I think there's a connection
I think once you have a political party
more and more of whose members are
believed in in in religious and
supernatural fantasies of a more and
more extravagant kind it it stands to
reason or to unreason that how you will
have a party that is more and more
inclined to embrace the fantastical in
its politics and policy believe whatever
you want in the privacy of your home the
privacy of your family in the privacy of
your church but when it bleeds over as
it inevitably has done in America to how
we manage and construct our economy and
our society and we're in trouble
[Music]